à partir de cette position gainerie
casse Parian a imaginé un maton 7 coups
prodigieux vous allez vite voir qu'il ne
partage avec Gary case par heure pas que
les initiales mais aussi un certain
talent tout commence par tout prend ses
6 un joli sacrifice de qualité et noir
logiquement reprennent la tour la Dame
Blanche vient donner un échec le roi
noir vient protéger son fou mais permet
un superbe sacrifice de dames processus
échec pour apprendre ici les blancs
peuvent désormais faire un double échec
à la découverte avec leur deux seules
pièces restantes le cavalier et le fou
le roi noir est obligé de s'extraire de
ces bases on vient reculer le cavalier
en Détroit pour faire un nouvel échec le
roi doit s'avancer jusqu'au cœur de
l'échiquier que les Blancs n'ont plus
d'échec mais je joue simplement roi des
deux et disent vos doigts à vous de
jouer et il y a en réalité aucune
défense contre la menace de faire échec
et mat juste avec le petit pion pour
illustrer admettons qu'on bouge la dame
et bien C3 vient délivrer le coup de
grâce avec juste donc un pion un fou un
cavalier